my next guest does a lot of big things
y'all he's a music mogul
songwriter artist and businessman now
he's turning his attention to feeding
the hungry as part of the all in
challenge dj khaled are you there how
you doing
i'm good how are you doing i'm all right
how's everything going with you
man well we have kids in isolation so
just you know imagine that
it's we're doing about as well as every
other parent in the world
but i mean how has isolation been for
you like what are you
are you doing anything different than
you normally would i mean you know i've
been watching a lot more movies than i
ever get in my life
but uh you know i'm enjoying the family
time me
my whole family we're really having fun
every day um besides you know i'm saying
turning on the news and seeing all the
um
stuff that's going on you know our
prayers go out to everybody out there
um and from the house we've been doing a
lot of just a lot of
you know we have we the best foundation
so we've been doing a lot of charity
work and getting with
the team every day how we can help
people you know saying that's so cool
that is so cool
um so where are you right now it looks
awesome
i'm in miami i'm in i'm in my backyard
um
the weather's amazing out here um and
you know we'd be working out
in the backyard playing basketball with
my son and
you know and on the weekends we have a
little barbecue
swim so we keeping the family time fun
and exciting especially for the kids
because you know i want my kids just to
be happy non-stop saying
no i i get it we i feel like i'm a clown
i'm always trying to entertain them
um so it looks awesome can we see a bit
where you i want to see where you're
barbie
i mean you know i'll show you some in
the backyard i like how do i flip it how
would i flip this okay
you know what i'm saying let me show you
guys you got a killer house what
oh yeah i work hard i work
my goddaughter's birthday today so my
son made a beautiful card
but um i'll show you this real quick
i'll show you this um just to remind us
that life is beautiful
yeah um and like a garden or something
because that's what i think
i actually have a piece of art that mr
brainwash gave me
just to remind me every day that life is
beautiful
oh my gosh that's so lovely
what an amazing reminder yeah we got the
infamous
lion because you know lying order you're
saying like yes
you know it's just beautiful man i can
show you my favorite my favorite plant
let me show you you know it's it's like
um
i love flowers i'm saying i love
landscaping
and um i'm sure you have one of these
you know i'm saying but
it's special for me i just love it
you're saying this
see how beautiful it is like oh my gosh
i
love it you know and i love sitting
right here you're saying matter of fact
i'm gonna sit here and talk to you
all right yeah sit down and relax yeah
you know just survive you know
yeah well you have another amazing
initiative going on
i love this so tell everybody about the
all-in challenge
shout out to michael rubin all in
challenge um is something that michael
rubin brought to the world
and it's helping all the people that's
in need
helping feeding the people and that's
why i i i'm
involved in the challenge and it's so
beautiful because artists like me and
other artists
and other entertainers united and um
like for instance drake is giving away
a chance to fly on his big jet yeah
concerts and just hang out with them i'm
gonna let people jet ski with me
um because i love justin and i'm gonna
take yeah and i'm gonna take them to
dinner
then you got like kevin hart that's
gonna let you be in a movie
um he's gonna give you your own trailer
and
um your own assistant then you got like
tom brady giving his first jersey away
yeah everybody's doing some cool stuff
it's it's amazing i plan on actually
joining too we're figuring out what
we're going to do
um because i'm like a few jobs we're
trying to figure out which thing to do
for combine them all but i
i saw and i saw everybody doing this and
i thought what a really cool way to
raise
money for people that really are
deserving of it and also
it's little it's little on our part to
do you know what i'm saying it's very
easy to take someone to dinner have a
good time
and then create a cool experience with a
fan um it's a really really smart thing
so thank you so much just for oh no it's
beautiful i i i want to thank
michael rubin for um for like you know
calling me and saying you know cal we
want you to be more involved
and anything to help the people is
something i love to do
um it's something that we do at the
calvin family all the time um
i also added some extra to my challenge
was i'm going to pay somebody's rent for
the whole year
in miami and that's when we the best
foundation
and um that's what it's about but i want
to remind people that we're going to
come out this
pandemic stronger better and greater but
even after this pandemic
we have to continue to unite we have to
continue to
help people that's in need we just got
to continue doing these beautiful things
and continue spreading the love because
love is the key all right y'all we'll go
online and check out the hashtag
all in challenge to see how you can take
part in some incredible experiences
and support those in need during this
pandemic there's some really cool
experiences you should really go check
it out it's crazy cool
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going